-Our next guest is a "New York
Times" best-selling author
whose new novel "Our Missing
Hearts" is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Celeste Ng,
everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back to the show!
-Thank you so much
for having me back on.
-Last time we had you,
which is a ways back now,
was for your book "Little Fires
Everywhere," which I loved.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which then became a television
miniseries with Reese
Witherspoon, Kerry Washington,
that you were an E.P. on.
What was it like to -- I'm
assuming when you first wrote
the book you never had any
assumption it would be adapted.
What was it like watching it
become a different medium?
-It was so surreal
in the best way.
I mean, writing a novel, you're
by yourself in your office.
It's really solitary.
And then a TV show has all these
people working on it.
It's such a team effort.
I mean, there's a room
full of writers.
It was just a really cool
experience to see.
-And obviously you now have
a relationship with Reese,
which is a pretty good person
to have a relationship with.
Reese's book club have
already picked this book,
which is a pretty high praise.
-I'm really honored. She does --
[ Cheers and applause ]
She does such great work,
I think, in trying to
lift up stories that get people
talking and having
conversations.
I really admire that about her.
-Your new book takes place
in a near but dystopic future.
And it's sort of written
from the perspective
of a child named Bird.
And I know you have
a son as well.
When you write about a child,
is it hard to separate it
from your own?
Are you inspired by it?
Or is it very different?
-I learn a little bit from him
because having a kid,
I remember both
how smart kids are,
how perceptive they are.
They see stuff
and they don't have
all the filters that we have.
So they just say it like it is.
They can see
a little more clearly.
And then you also remember how
kind of innocent they are,
how there are some things that
just go right over their heads.
And it's both those things
at the same time.
-And also the book is about
a relationship
with a mother and son.
When you write a book that's
about a mother and son, do you
ever worry that years from now
your son will read it and say,
"I never saw it like this"?
[ Laughter ]
-A little bit, but you
know what? He might do that,
and then maybe he'll write his
own stories,
and that seems
like a good thing too.
-That's a pretty good thing.
Is he too young to tell whether
or not he has any strength
as a storyteller or any
inclination towards it?
-He's always making up stories
and drawings,
but he claims that
he doesn't like reading.
So I'm just kind of
not saying anything.
I'm just going to see
how this comes out.
-Do you feel like that's his way
of rebelling against
the fact that his mom
is an author?
-I wonder that sometimes.
He's like,
"I don't really like books."
And I'm like --
[ Laughter ]
-It's a very funny position
to take.
Like, "I'm not a book guy."
-That's the rebellion
you're taking?
-Yeah, that's the rebellion.
I think -- Obviously, one of
the things that has inspired
this book and has happened
since we last saw each other,
the election of Donald Trump,
a lot of the rise in anti-Asian
hate crime here in this country.
Is writing about it, do you feel
like you're trying to inform,
trying to educate,
or is it catharsis?
How do you approach it?
-It's a little bit
all the above.
I mean, I wasn't sure if I
wanted to put that into the book
because it's a dark thing
to think about.
It's something I've been aware
of growing up
as a Chinese-American woman
that violence could be part of
my life at any point in time.
But when we started seeing all
these things that are getting
caught on tape, people who are
just being beaten,
it felt really important to look
that right in the face
in the book, and say,
"Okay, if you didn't know
it was happening, now you know.
And what are you going to do
about it?"
-With that said,
the book has a very sort of
optimistic tilt to it,
which I think
is important to let
readers know.
Was that important as well as
you talk about, especially,
you know, a slightly darker
future to make sure that
you also see the opportunity
for lightness at the end of it?
-Yeah, I'm so glad
you said that because a lot of
this book was me figuring out,
how do you hold on to hope
when it feels like the world is
falling apart?
How do you give hope to your
children and encourage them
to think that they can make
a difference
when it really feels like
everything is going badly?
-Yeah.
-I just feel -- I'm like,
"Don't say that."
[ Laughter ]
-You wrote -- "Little Fires"
took place in Shaker,
where you lived.
And now you live in Cambridge,
and it takes place there.
I think, especially when you're
talking about very real issues,
sometimes the communities you
write about might be a little
sensitive to the way
that you saw them.
Do you feel like
that's happening
with this book as well
or do you worry
that it happens with this book
or that is something you embrace
as part of
the writing challenge?
-Well, now I'm thinking
about it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I set the book in Cambridge
partly because it's my home.
It's been where I've lived
the longest of my adult life.
But also because I think we
think about places like that
and in that the Northeast
as being a liberal bubble,
and we have this idea, "Oh, that
stuff can't happen here."
But the truth is that
it happens everywhere.
And it felt like a way of sort
of asking people again to think,
"Hey, it happens. What are
you going to do about it?"
-Now, I do feel, even though
you're one of our favorite
guests to be on the show,
the issue with authors is
I feel like we need to give you
five years to write another book
before you can come back.
-I keep thinking
I'm going to get faster,
and I actually think
I'm getting slower.
[ Laughter ]
-Last time you were here,
"Little Fires"
barely had come out.
And then it became --
let's just put it this way --
people on our staff were a lot
more excited you were here
this time than they were
the first time.
Even when I came backstage to
your dressing room, a lot of
people were asking you
to sign this book for them.
And I think that speaks to
the success of that last book.
When you sit down to write a new
one, does it make it a little
bit harder when the last one
is a book everybody read?
-A little bit. I mean,
the way I think about it is
more like I try and think of
people are in my corner
and I want to do right by them.
I want to write a book that
they're going to be
excited about.
I don't want to
just phone it in.
So if it takes longer,
that's why.
-Well, I think we all
support that.
And it's just so lovely to have
you here again.
We will see you in --
If you need six,
we'll make it six, alright?
Thanks so much for being here.
You guys, Celeste Ng.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Our Missing Hearts"
is available now
wherever books are sold,
but please support
local and independent
bookstores.
We will be right back.